- [Voiceover] Let f of x
equal three to the negative x
minus five, and g of x equals
negative x to the third
minus four x-squared plus x plus six.
The graphs of y equals f
of x and y equals g of x
are shown below, and we
see them right over here.
This y equals f of x is
in that purplish color.
Let me see if I can get
that same purplish color.
So, that is, in that.
So, let me underline it now.
So, f of x is
in that purplish color.
So y equal f of x, that's
right over here in purple.
And then y equals g of x, that is in blue.
So y equals g of x.
g of x is defined right over there.
y equals g of x, well that
is graphed in the blue.
And we see that they intersect
at the point a comma b.
So there's a couple of
ways to think about this.
We could say that when x is equal to a,
f of x and g of x equal each other.
Or, we could say, f of a,
and this is coming from
this point of intersection.
Let me draw a little arrow here.
Or a big arrow.
That point of intersection lets us know
that f of a,
f of a is equal to g of a.
Is equal to g of a, which is equal to b.
g of a, which is equal to b.
They both, if you input
a into the function f
you're going to get b.
If you input a into the function g,
And so the point a comma
b is on both graphs.
Both y equals g of x and y equals f of x.
And so from here, you could
make some interesting statements.
For example, you could just
say, well, what is f of a?
f of a is 3 to the negative a power
minus five, is going to be equal to,
what's g of a?
g of a is negative a to the third
minus four a-squared
plus a plus six, so you could say this.
And that would be equal to that.
Either of those would be equal to b.
Alright, I think we've
analyzed that a good bit,
so now let's actually
answer their questions.
And normally I'd suggest
you look at the questions
before you actually try to solve it,
but I just wanted to do this
just to really squeeze out
as much as we could out of
the information they gave us.
So they tell us the value
x equals a is the solution
to which of the following equations?
Select all that apply.
So this first one is three
to the negative x minus five
is equal to b.
Well, we already know that,
we already know that three
to the negative a minus five,
Three to the negative a minus
is going to be equal to b.
Is going to be equal to b.
This over here, this is
equivalent to saying,
this is equivalent to saying f of x,
f of x is equal to b.
And we know f of x
equals B when x equals a.
When x equals a, f of x is equal to b.
This expression is equal to b.
So we know that that first one is true.
Now the second one is just saying,
f of x is equal to g of x.
Well, we know that when x is equal to a,
That f of a is equal to g of a.
Because, as a reminder,
this right over here
is our definition for f of x,
and this over here is
our definition of g of x.
So this is just saying
f of x equals g of x,
when does that happen?
Well, that happens when x equals a.
We already saw it up here.
f of a is equal to g of a.
They both equal b.
And so both of these are going to be
equal to each other when x is equal to A.
So I will check that one as well.